こんにちは
食べ物大好き肇社長です皆さんマック行った時にセットとか出たら元ポテトよく食べる
と思うんですよ僕は食べないんですけどね
ポツダム好きじゃなくていつもはバーガー遠ざかるの見本となってたのですなあところ
座
というよりでマックのポイント a サイズがあると思うんですけども会でサイズは
170グラム入っていますこちらですねこれが170g 340g 510g 680
850店20銭20g
はーはっはっはっ
私は気づいてしまってポテトってなんかぷらが応募そうに見えると思うんですよ皆さん
た武装をてる人は多いと思いますでもそんなことはなくてポテトは所詮はジャガイモ畑
から採れる野菜の一種のポテト a 昨年安全グラムが6個合計1,020g 約1
キロのポテトがありますでカロリーが81個534kcal なんでああ
今回で3200円4kcal あります
で僕を持ったんですよ普段ハンバーガーが食べてるからお腹が膨らむように見えると
思うんですけど実際ここでとってお腹膨らまない説
と思うんですよいやマジで初戦はだけ野菜ですからね
何きっと今お腹がすいてで僕だとお腹が膨れないんでも食べても食べても止まらないん
でも感覚が麻痺してあったり3000kcal 来るんじゃねぇかなと思いまして今回
はポテト1黒グラブ
食べてみようと思います
一人でなかもよいただきないやまず思ったより多く見えないんだからもっとこういうの
だと思ってたんですけど1キロがわりとこじんまりせて
な痒そうですねじゃあもうちょっとしなってきてるねすぐ食べると思いますいただき
ます
前で僕どつかれたしなしなポテトの方が好きなんですよね
じゃがいもかがちゃんとありません
群馬デップん
ね content i 言えば馬でもなぁ
わざわざ食べようと思わないんですよねー
吉これやばいも6
かもしれないな
ん
me
は待って本当に多いな家なってるからなんかちょっとちょっとって言ってるけど多分
上げ種だったらほんとこういうスタイルでしたね
これやばい過去最強に追加もしれん
勇敢なポテトにサーチャー0
[音楽]
ちょっとケチャップ使います味変がに一番多分効果的なんでしょうね同じ安直て
いただきてしまいますのでこれでちょっと味を
んをっ
変わんねーなー根本的な部分は多少マジになるんでちょっとケチャップでもうちょっと
食べてみます
まじやばい
まじやばい俺ほんとやばい
うううう
none
うーん
[音楽]
ん
大変これ大変だえっ
これすごいねます人じゃねぇ
[音楽]
大変なぁと言いませんまち米なく無理に作ってるん
全部食べたいんでー
出でよ送還中はっはいパッカーズ fuck パーク
て作るぞビデオエロだった
ああああああああ
[音楽]
仲間じゃない元の量を見てないからわからないんですけどもっとが今後位
あページャーも激昂がんばったらねマジで来たすげー
2人でもでも16たちすごいからんように行けると思ってました
そこ墓がねぇそこ墓とねものがある来いさ
[音楽]
多分選択が務めます
いっ
あとは
曲がらずいっ
[音楽]
見て
カンブリア紀にいたおば日にあ
[音楽]
顔
意見ユーチューバーがする顔じゃねぇ待ってやばいやばい油がすごいリセット飲んでも
効かんぜ俺ダメリセッター
なものじゃないですよね油ですよあれ
[音楽]
はぁっ
売ったっ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
ねポテトサラダだもん勝ち勝ち0
マジでござい
予想
ああああああああ
結構降ってるよ m 贈った歌したら一人で生きた
これは元ば匂いっていう
こんぐらいなんだえっこんくらいの金くらいを残したんじゃなくて
グライド今ぐらいのことねぇ
me
ええええええ
あっはっ